[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
noch sieht es nach gleichschritt aus die
ampel koalitionäre auf ihrem weg
richtung regierungsübernahme heute mit
der präsentation des koalitionsvertrags
guten abend interessant war nicht nur
was präsentiert wurde sondern auch wie
erst olaf scholz in bekannter
nüchternheit und kürze wichtigste
botschaft zitat die ampel steht danach
wortreicher robert habeck mit emotionen
und pathos und psychologischen
einblicken in die zwischenmenschliche
dynamik von koalitionsverhandlungen
und schließlich christian lindner der
viel über optimierung und modernisierung
sprach und am ende noch haltungsnoten an
den künftigen kanzler scholz vergangen
worüber er wenig fast pflicht schuldig
nur in den jeweiligen eingang statements
gesprochen wurde war das aktuell
brennendste thema die aus der kontrolle
geratene pandemie die mit heute fast
67.000 gemeldeten neuinfektionen
keinerlei bremsspuren aufweist das wirft
fragen auf die ich kurz vor der sendung
olaf scholz gestellt habe doch zunächst
der bericht aus berlin von patricia
wiedemeier
selten wurde jeder schritt eine
regierungsbildung so inszeniert selten
lief eine regierungsbildung so
geräuschlos ab selten drang so wenig
nach draußen der koalitionsvertrag
digital abrufbar
die ampel sie gibt sich fortschrittlich
modern anders eben als alle
vorgängerregierungen self es als neues
kommunikationsmittel mehr fortschritt
wagen ist dann auch der titel des
koalitionsvertrages es soll eine
koalition auf augenhöhe sein keine
politik des kleinsten gemeinsamen
nenners eine politik der großen wirkung
und sein der glaube an den fortschritt
und daran dass politik etwas gutes
bewirken kann uns eint der wille das
land besser zu machen es voran zu
bringen und es beisammen zu halten nicht
alle drei parteien loben die gute
effektive zusammenarbeit in den letzten
wochen jeder habe irgendwo kompromisse
machen müssen in einer dreier
konstellation kann sich niemand zu 100
prozent durchsetzen
war es aber eine möglichkeit gibt auch
mal den standpunkt zu wechseln und zu
verstehen dass wenn christian lindner
eine 6 auf der seite sieht und welche
einen neuen sehen dass wir vielleicht
beide recht haben können ein bündnis für
freiheit gerechtigkeit und vor allem
mehr klimaschutz verspricht die ampel
das ziel der klimaneutralität zieht sich
durch alle bereiche für alle gesetze
soll es einen klima check geben das leid
wird dieser regierung ist eine handelnde
gesellschaft ein investieren der staat
und in deutschland das schlichtweg
funktioniert in einer zeit wo so viel
sorge angst und verunsicherung da ist es
ist wichtig dass wenigstens ab und zu
ein zeichen ein dokument in diesem fall
des mutes und der zuversicht gegeben
wird jedem anfang wohnt ein zauber
ernähren das ist tatsächlich auch weiß
was ich heute empfinde das muss ich ganz
ehrlich zu sagen wir sind überzeugt
dieser anfang ist uns gelungen dieses
bündnis steht für zukunft es ist für die
zukunft gemacht wir haben
außerordentlich ambitionierte vorhaben
und deshalb
spüren wir demut
angesichts der dimension dessen was wir
uns vorgenommen haben
zuversicht ja auch demut in zeiten von
corona zuversicht dass der richtige mann
an der spitze steht ungewöhnliche
lobeshymnen ausgerechnet von der fdp
vielleicht weil sie diesmal gut
behandelt wurde und viel durchgesetzt
hat olaf scholz verfügt über ein inneres
geländer
um aus einer klaren werthaltung heraus
dieses land nach vorne zu führen und
weit mehr menschen zu repräsentieren als
nur sozialdemokratisch grün oder liberal
gewählt haben und deshalb wird olaf
scholz ein starker bundeskanzler der
bundesrepublik deutschland sein die
ersten reaktionen der opposition
erwartet ba der koalitionsvertrag hat
viele viele warme butter an allerdings
hätte mir da zum beispiel die umsetzung
und die leerstände das ganze ist mir
nicht von ihrem ziel es drohen auf allen
ebenen mehr staatliche eingriffe mehr
gängelung mehr finanzielle belastung und
damit weniger freiheit es bleiben viele
offene fragen vor allem nach der
finanzierung doch das erste wichtigste
thema dieser neuen regierung ist die
korona krise olaf scholz kündigt die
einführung eines bund länder krisenstab
es an und prämien für das pflegepersonal
jedoch keine allgemeine impfpflicht
impfen ist der ausweg aus dieser
pandemie in einrichtung in den besonders
wohlhabende gruppen betreut werden
sollten wir die impfung verpflichtend
machen eine ausweitung dieser regelung
bleibt zu prüfen
es war heute viel die rede von mut von
aufbruch und geschlossenheit sie wird es
brauchen die neue ampel regierung
zuallererst für die bekämpfung der
korona krise
den koalitionsvertrag den schauen wir
uns jetzt nochmal näher an und genauso
interessant ist natürlich auch die frage
wer bekommt welches ressort und welche
personen ziehen in die ministerien ein
der zuschnitt ist bekannt die person
noch nicht alle zündstoff ist aber schon
zu erkennen etwa beim
verkehrsministerium das für den
klimaschutz und die verkehrswende
natürlich zentral ist geht aber dicht an
die grünen sondern an die fdp
interessant wird auch die besetzung des
gesundheitsministeriums andreas cüppers
über inhalte und den künftigen
stuhlkreis am kabinettstisch
ein hartriegel gewächs da wird sie sich
aber freuen angela merkel bekommt einen
baum zu ihrer 650 kabinettssitzung und
einen fast ebenso großen blumenstrauß
zwischen merkels letzter und scholz
erster regierung liegen noch zwölf tage
an denen der koalitionsvertrag die basis
dreier parteien überzeugen muss der
koalitions chef geht da selbstbewusst
ran aus meiner sicht geht es um die
größte industrielle modernisierung
deutschlands ein weit über 100 jahren
als erfolg schreibt sich die spd die
erhöhung des mindestlohns auf 12 euro zu
nicht gelungen ist die belastung höhere
vermögen aber das hauptthema der
regierung scholz heißt klimaschutz
robert habeck bekommt als vizekanzler
und klimaminister die macht über ein
erweitertes wirtschaftsministerium die
grünen haben erreicht dass beim
kohleausstieg das datum 20 30 steht und
nicht erreicht das habe kein vetorecht
bekommt wir haben aber einen mechanismus
etabliert wir haben jetzt klima check
genannt dass jedes gesetzesvorhaben auf
seine klimawirkung
überprüft werden muss fdp chef lindner
wird es als finanzminister mit dem
größten problem der ampel zu tun
bekommen dass die finanzierung der
milliarden vorhaben unklar ist mit dem
ihm zustehenden vetorecht will lindner
sicherstellen dass deutschland die
stabilitätspolitik nicht verlässt das
wichtigste mittel dagegen ist dass der
staat solide mit dem geld umgeht und das
ist gesichert denn es gibt keine
steuererhöhungen und die schuldenbremse
die werden der respektieren als
außenministerin will annalena baerbock
signale nach russland senden im
koalitionsvertrag steht nicht mehr gutes
verhältnis sondern stabiles zur
verbesserung will deutschland allen
jungen russen visafreiheit anbieten
außerdem werden die grünen dass familien
das umwelt- und das
landwirtschaftsministerium leiten ob es
die favoriten werden soll morgen
mitgeteilt werden die vielleicht größte
überraschung die fdp bekommt das
ministerium für verkehr und digitales
minister wird volker wissing hier
zeichnen sich konflikte ab im verkehr
style sind relativ viele formulierungen
noch sehr offen gehalten beispielsweise
mit blick auf den bau von neuen autobahn
auf den blick zum neuen
bundesverkehrswegeplan und da werden wir
weiter druck machen dass ich da auch
wirklich spürbar etwas verändert und
auch der verkehrsbereich dazu beitragen
wird dass die klimaziele endlich
eingehalten werden als justizminister
schickt die fdp marco buschmann ins
kabinett als bildungsministerin bettina
stark watzinger bei der spd gilt
hubertus heil erneut gesetzt als
arbeitsminister noch offen wer innen wer
bau der entwicklungs und der
verteidigungsminister wird anstelle des
2 prozent ziels der nato soll 1 3
prozent ziel treten das aber auch
diplomatie und entwicklungshilfe enthält
als einer der unbeliebtesten jobs wie
der des gesundheitsministers obwohl die
spd mit karl lauterbach einen hätte der
ihn gerne hätte das sind die umrisse des
kabinetts scholz das am 6 dezember
anfangen will zu regieren
tja und der mutmasslich künftige
bundeskanzler olaf scholz lässt uns aus
berlin zugeschaltet guten abend herr
scholz
immer die veranstaltung die präsentation
des koalitionsvertrags heute beobachtete
dann haben sie am anfang erstmal über
corona geredet über den ernst der lage
das waren so 400 minuten also ziemlich
wenig zeit oder wurde eigentlich auch
nichts neues verkündet mit anderen
worten die warnungen der kanzlerin die
auch gestern sich ja noch mal mit ihnen
allen getroffen hat die sind
letztendlich verhalten richtig ja meine
ernste lage heute treten die ganzen
neuen gesetze in kraft die wir auf den
weg gebracht haben da sind eine ganze
reihe auch von präzisierung und
verschärfung mit verbunden zum beispiel
3g am arbeitsplatz also dass man dort
geimpft genesen und oder getestet
erscheinen muss das gleiche für den
öffentlichen verkehr das hatten wir
bisher nicht und es gibt jetzt überall
umsetzungsschritte in den ländern die
sehr entschieden sind indem wir den
zugang zu einer ganzen reihe von
angeboten
begrenzen auf diejenigen geimpft und
genesen sind und wenn es besonders
streng sein muss eben auch noch
zusätzliche tests verlangen und das
glaube ich ist auch der richtige weg
deshalb brauchen wir jetzt eine klare
strategie für den weiteren umgang mit
dieser situation
und dazu gehört dass wir ein
expertengremium etablieren das sich auf
gemeinsame erkenntnisse festlegt die
dann in die entscheidung einfließen
können und dass wir einen krisenstab
zusammen mit den ländern etablieren wo
wir auch die situation jeden tag jede
woche neu bewerten und daraus die
notwendigen konsequenzen ableiten
erfolgs das gibt es ja längst also es
fällt ja überhaupt nicht an zahlen daten
fakten das findet auch nicht eine
expertise und für die täglichen
sachverständigen berichte sorgt bisher
das ak ii neben vielen anderen also
warum brauchen sich also mal experten
die konkret werden wir haben noch die
experten und wir haben die konkreten
erkenntnisse wir haben eine ganze reihe
von erkenntnissen aber sehr
unterschiedliche vorschläge zu den
konsequenzen der dirigierende sogar und
deshalb muss man das genau betrachten
noch die verschiedenen dient aus ganz
unterschiedlichen perspektiven
ratschläge geben zusammenbinden damit
man daraus dann richtige gemeinsam
abgewogene vorschläge bekommt und
konkret geht es natürlich auch darum
dass wir wegkommen von
ankündigungspolitik wo irgendwelche
maßnahmen erklärt werden aber dann nicht
realisiert werden ich will jedenfalls
dass wenn wir uns miteinander darauf
festgelegt haben dass jetzt alle in den
altenpflegeeinrichtungen gepustet werden
auch wissen ob das überall und in
welchem tempo geschieht wenn wir zum
beispiel demnächst und darauf haben sich
ja viele verständigt beschließen dass es
in solchen einrichtungen für diejenigen
wird beschäftigt sind eine impfpflicht
gibt dann wollen wir ja auch wissen wie
weit die umgesetzt wird wo wir dastehen
das gleiche gilt für die dinge über die
wir eben geredet haben also es geht auch
immer um umsetzung viele beklagen ja zum
beispiel auch dass es jetzt beschränkung
gibt die gar nicht kontrolliert werden
auch das muss sich ändern da muss man
dann einen klaren gemeinsamen blick
entwickeln deshalb diese gemeinsamen
krisenstab es gibt ja durchaus einen
stand der wissenschaft es gab auch
bisher schon krisenstäbe und es gibt
eine kanzlerin die vor einem jahr schon
mal warnte und sagte bei einem
exponentiellen wachstum diesmal sagt sie
wir sind in einer lage die alles
übertreffen wird was man sich im moment
was wir bisher hatten und auch was sich
manche bisher vorstellen können warum
wiederholt sich jetzt geschichte schon
wieder sie hat ja offenbar einen lock
down vorgeschlagen ein schnelles hit
heart fast jetzt noch wo sie ich weiß
nicht wo sie das hier haben aber auf
alle fälle ist das aus meiner sicht
jetzt richtig dass wir all die dinge
umsetzen die wir machen man kann das ja
zum beispiel an einem punkt sehen wir
haben impfstoff verfügbar ist und
trotzdem ist nicht geschafft dass
genügend bürgerinnen und bürger davon
gebrauch gemacht haben das ist eine
frage des doing und das muss sich
dringend ändern es reicht nicht
beschlüsse zu fassen das muss sicher
sein dass in allen 16 ländern in allen
401 landkreisen und kreisfreien städten
überall in deutschland diese dinge
durchgesetzt und umgesetzt werden das
gilt auch für das boostern dass wir das
nicht schon längst angefangen haben das
ist in der tat ein punkt über den man
diskutieren kann aber jetzt müssen wir
doch ein system etablieren indem
sichergestellt wird dass ein so
ehrgeiziges vorhaben wie das bis zum
ende des jahres all diejenigen die in
der ersten jahreshälfte eine zweite
impfung bekommen haben das sind knapp 30
millionen bürgern und bürger auch mit
der dritten impfung im laufe dieses zu
ende gehenden jahres zu versehen
umzusetzen und solche handhabbaren
praktischen und dann auch durch
gesetzten schritte die sind es die wir
jetzt brauchen aber da läuft ihnen die
zeit weg und morgen läuft jetzt erstmal
die rechtsgrundlage epidemische notlager
nationaler tragweite aus das heißt dass
die länder dann wenn es nötig sein
sollte denn oder wenn sie es für nötig
befinden sollten in den nächsten tagen
und wochen viele maßnahmen nicht mehr
ergreifen können es gibt dann einfach
nicht mehr es sind sehr viele maßnahmen
dort auch neu entstanden und die dann
nicht mangelt lässt welcher weise gibt
es ja darum maßnahmen durchzusetzen und
deshalb glaube ich ist das genau der
unterschied den wir jetzt brauchen es
reicht nicht aus abstrakt erwägung
anzustellen man muss es tun und zwar
dann nicht irgendwo sondern überall in
deutschland glauben sie denn dass selbst
das 2g und 3g und noch weitere impfwelle
dieses rasante wachstum bremsen werden
oder sagen sie das jetzt aus rücksicht
auf die fdp die sich ja noch in so einer
relativ steilen lernkurve was krone
angeht befindet es sind ja doch sehr
präzise sehr weitreichende maßnahmen die
über alles hinaus gehen was in letzter
zeit gegolten hat und vor allem wenn sie
überall umgesetzt und realisiert werden
dann hat das einen massiven effekt aus
meiner sicht muss man aber deshalb ja
auch der krisenstab die lage regelmäßig
beobachten und daraus die notwendigen
schritte ableiten und es darf niemals
jemand gegen der sagt irgendwas geht
nicht wenn es notwendig ist muss es
getan werden dazu zählt ja zum beispiel
auch in dem regime das jetzt gesetzlich
scharf neu gestellt worden ist die
möglichkeit kontakt beschränkung zu
verhängen wenn das erforderlich ist also
da ist ein ganz großes waffenarsenal und
es geht jetzt darum es nicht nur zu
zeigen sondern auch zu nutzen wo es
notwendig ist es jetzt aus mit empfiehlt
ich bin dafür und ich glaube dafür gibt
es jetzt auch eine gesetzgebung mehrheit
jedenfalls ist das mein sicherer
eindruck dass wir in den einrichtungen
wo viele schutzbedürftige sind
impfpflicht für diejenigen durchsetzen
die dort beschäftigt sind zum schutz zb
der bewohnerinnen und bewohner von
altenpflegeeinrichtungen aber nicht nur
dort ich meine gleichzeitig müssen wir
den nächsten schritt auch
mitdiskutieren also darüber reden ob
weitere schritte notwendig sind
gegenwärtig stehen ganz viele bürgern
und bürger an den impfzentren an und
unsere erste aufgabe die wir jetzt haben
ist dafür zu sorgen dass es genug
impfzentren gibt das in den arztpraxen
genug impfstoff verfügbar ist dass die
engagierten ärzten ärzte in deutschland
alle ihre
patientinnen und patienten hatte
diejenigen die bei ihnen hilfe suchen
dann auch mit einer impfung versehen
kann das ist ein großer
organisatorischer kraftakt um den müssen
wir uns jetzt kümmern ist meinte jetzt
aber eine allgemeine impfpflicht darauf
zielte meine frage ob scheint es bei
ihnen der spd sehr unterschiedliche
ansichten zu geben der frühere
justizminister minister und noch
amtierende außenminister heiko maas hat
das abgelehnt hat gesagt das wird nicht
kommen ist auch nicht nötig andere in
ihrer parteien den ländern zb michael
müller sehen das anders und ich sage
ihnen ganz klar es ist richtig dass
diese diskussion beginnt es ist richtig
dass wir anders als das jemals der fall
war jetzt die kraft haben
gesetzgeberisch für bestimmte
berufsgruppen und einrichtungen solche
vorschriften zu machen das halte ich für
einen großen fortschritt und ehrlicher
weise finde ich es besonders
bemerkenswert dass in dieser debatte
viele teilnehmen die sich wenig ums
impfen gekümmert haben dort wo sie
verantwortung tragen aber mal abstrakte
erwägungen anstellen ich glaube
ausschließen darf man nichts und mit dem
ersten schritt ist natürlich auch die
debatte über den zweiten eröffnet jetzt
aber er ist mein großer wunsch dass
überall in deutschland sich alle
zusammenreißen dass wir genau im zentrum
haben genug mobile impfangebot dass
genug impfstoff ist in allen
hausarztpraxen weil das ist das was wir
jetzt machen wollen wenn wir 30
millionen bürgerinnen und bürger ostern
wollen mit einer auffrischungsimpfung
versehen wollen dann ist das eine
riesige leistung und da müssen alle
zusammenhalten für dieses impfen wird
ist vor allem natürlich also die
impfstoff besorgungen und verteilung und
viele fragen diesem zusammenhang ist vor
allem ein gesundheitsminister oder
ministerin zuständig da wirkt die spd
der das jetzt zu gefallen ist die dass
möglicherweise auch gar nicht wollte
dieses ressort irgendwie unvorbereitet
wenn er sie können ja bisher noch nicht
meinen namen nennen und die die
kursieren sind mit verlaub unbekannt
also was sie zu hören weiß ich nicht mit
mir hat darüber keiner gesprochen und
kann es auch nicht weil wir jetzt uns
die wenigen tage die wir bis zur
regierungsbildung haben
vorgenommen haben ein sehr sehr gutes
kabinett zu bilden mit erstklassigen
frauen und männern über die die
bürgerinnen bürger dieses landes
begeistert sein werden ist dann ja kein
lauterbach dabei als
gesundheitsminister schon gedanken dass
sie gerne dabei wäre der
sozialdemokratische anwärter auf das
kanzleramt mit verschiedenen anderen
sich gut berät über die frage wie man
ein kabinett zusammenstellt aber
klugerweise ist das ein vorgang der
diskret stattfindet wie übrigens ja auch
die koalitionsverhandlungen das stimmt
die wahren diskrete stichwort koalition
sie waren lange genug finanzminister um
zu wissen ist dass das mit abstand
wichtigste und mächtigste ressort ist es
ist aufgeteilt in spiegel ressorts für
alle anderen ministerien sie wissen mehr
über die anderen ministerien als jeder
andere sieg und veto einlegen also ein
finanzminister kann wirklich eine
stempel aufdrücken einer regierung und
das geht jetzt an die fdp das wird mit
ziemlich gelbe regierung kann das sein
soweit ich weiß werde ich jetzt kanzler
genau aber sie wissen wie mächtig das
amt des finanzministers es trotzdem weil
ich gerne finanzminister und werde jetzt
gern der nächste kanzler aber es hat
keine frage dass er keine antwort auf
meine frage wie viel gewicht die fdp mit
diesem ministerium in dieser neuen
koalition hat alle ministerien haben
gewicht in dieser koalition und das was
die künftige regierung auszeichnen wird
ist die tatsache dass alle
zusammenarbeiten
das werden sie auch sehen jede woche
jeden monat die ganzen jahre über denn
es geht darum gemeinsam gut zu regieren
und die kraft zu bündeln
nicht gegeneinander zu arbeiten und
deshalb wird der finanzminister genauso
wie derjenige wird verantwortlich ist
für wirtschaft und klimaschutz wie
diejenigen die sich um die bundeswehr
kümmern wie diejenigen die sich um
arbeit und soziales oder gesundheit
kümmern zusammenarbeiten nur gemeinsam
gelingt das werk und genau das haben wir
uns vorgenommen aber sie wissen ja
vornamen vornehmen kann man sich viel im
regieren es dann wenn politik auf
realität stößt und dann geht es eben
nicht immer so gemeinsam also man sieht
ja bei der ressortaufteilung schon wo da
eine der größten konflikte liegen wird
das verkehrsministerium was ganz viel
mit klimaschutz und verkehrswende zu tun
hat bei der fdp und die umweltschutz und
klimaschutz ministerien mittelmäßig
mächtig bei den grünen wie lange dauert
das was ist da knallt es wird gar nicht
knallen das gibt um meine fortschritte
koalition um einen aufbruch und
natürlich gibt es ganz viele die so ein
bild von politik haben als ob es nur um
eine theateraufführung gegner und jeder
spielt so sein spiel es geht doch hier
darum zusammenzuarbeiten und das haben
sich alle vorgenommen das wird wirklich
eine andere regierung sein als wir sie
kennen in deutschland das ist eine neue
ein neues bündnis dass viele
zusammenführt und das eine große kraft
hat und deshalb ist es ja etwas
bemerkenswertes dass die drei parteien
die jetzt diese regierung gebildet haben
die es so bisher für deutschland noch
nicht gegeben hat eine koalition von spd
grünen und fdp dass das eine regierung
ist die auch gerne sich um die
wiederwahl bewirbt gemeinsam in vier
jahren und wenn man das im blick hat
dann muss man vom ersten tag an
zusammenarbeiten und einen gesang
mannschafts werk zustande bringen und
genau das wird passieren und wir werden
das beobachten er stolz danken für das
gespräch vielen dank
zur vorstellung des koalitionsvertrags
nun ein kommentar von redaktionsleiter
des heute-journals burg schließe
kein bundeskanzler der spd stand vor
einem so schwierigen start die olaf
scholz nicht brand nicht schmidt nicht
schröder scholz wird beginnen inmitten
einer exponentiellen krise deren ausgang
nicht absehbar ist niemand weiß wie sehr
corona deutschland verändern wird wohin
die stimmung kippt auch gegenüber der
künftigen regierung die ihren kurs zur
allgemeinen impfpflicht erst noch finden
muss es muss jetzt alles sehr schnell
gehen gut dass das interregnum diese
phase der zwischen regierung bald endet
die ampel parteien haben zügelte
verhandelt nichts erinnerte an die
maßlose zeitverschwendung vor vier
jahren als union grüne und fdp auf
balkonien eine annäherung da boten die
am ende scheiterte die ampel leute haben
diesmal nicht lange rum sondiert in 22
geradezu unsichtbaren arbeitsgruppen
sind ganz konkrete texte entstanden die
nun die einzelnen kapitel des
koalitionsvertrags bilden so
zielgerichtet lief das und das muss so
bleiben die lage draußen im land ist zum
zerreißen gespannt
daher muss dieser vertrag so belastbar
sein dass er die vormaligen politischen
gegner beisammen hält die
koalitionsparteien haben sich die
ressorts nach ihren kernthemen
untereinander aufgeteilt an die grünen
geht klima die fdp bekommt finanzen und
die spd soziales durch alleingänge darf
es deswegen nicht geben denn wenn die
korona schuldenuhr noch lange so rasant
weiter läuft dann werden alle drei
parteien gleichermaßen ihre klientel
enttäuschen und sollten sich die
künftigen regierungspartner darüber im
streit verlieren dann könnte die
staatsverdrossenheit noch größer werden
und mit ihr das corona chaos
auf spieße kommentierte reaktionen zum
ampel vertrag gibt es nachher auch noch
im heute-journal update unter anderem
ein interview mit cdu fraktionschef
ralph brinkhaus natürlich finden sie
jede menge infos zum koalitionsvertrag
bei uns online auf zdf heute und jetzt
erstmal die nachrichten
um die korona welle in deutschland unter
kontrolle zu bringen gilt ab heute am
arbeitsplatz und im öffentlichen
nahverkehr die 3g regel was ab sofort
zumindest stichprobenartig
kontrolliert werden muss bei
nichtbeachtung drohen bußgelder von bis
zu 2500 euro vielerorts fehlt den
verkehrsbetrieben der polizei und den
ordnungsämtern allerdings dazu das
personal die deutsche bahn zog zum
auftakt ein positives fazit
angesichts steigender corona zahlen wird
weiter heftig über eine allgemeine
impfpflicht diskutiert dabei zeichnet
sich eine solche für beschäftigte von
einrichtungen ab in denen verletzliche
gruppen betreut werden die impfungen
nehmen derweil fahrt auf gestern gab es
so viele impfungen wie seit ende juli
nicht insgesamt 638 1000 darunter
84.000 erstimpfungen ein zwei monats
höchststand
die sieben tage incidents ist laut
robert koch institut weiter gestiegen
auf 404,5 knapp 67.000 neuinfektionen
gab es heute über 14.000 mehr als
vergangenen mittwoch und
335 weitere todesfälle in der slowakei
hat die regierung wegen rasant
steigender infektionszahlen einen
zweiwöchigen lockdown verhängt ab
freitag für alle ungeimpfte und geimpfte
das haus die wohnung verlassen dürfen
slowakische bürger nur um lebensmittel
einzukaufen zur schule oder zur arbeit
zu fahren oder um sich impfen zu lassen
die slowakei hat mit 1300 die höchste
sieben tage incidents in der eu
der justizausschuss des thüringer
landtages hat die immunität des afg
fraktionsvorsitzenden björn rücker
aufgehoben somit muss sich der vom
verfassungsschutz als rechtsextrem
eingestufte politiker ermittlungen
stellen gegen höcke war im juni
strafanzeige gestellt worden weil er
eine rede mit einem wahlspruch der as a
beendet haben soll der kampf druck der
nationalsozialisten
die belarussische oppositionspolitikerin
janowski hat vor dem europa parlament
die eu aufgefordert aktiv gegen den
machthaber lukaschenko vorzugehen die
ich an oskar ja die selbst im exil lebt
erinnerte an über 800 politische
gefangene und forderte mehr
unterstützung für die opposition in
belarus die eu dürfe das regime in minsk
nicht durch diplomatischen dialog
legitimieren noch immer harren tausende
migranten an der belarussische
polnischen grenze aus morgen wollen sich
kanzlerin merkel und der polnische
regierungschefs beraten
im ärmelkanal ist ein boot mit migranten
in seenot geraten mindestens 31 menschen
kamen ums leben bei der rettungsaktion
wurden von frankreich aus auch
hubschrauber eingesetzt das boot
kenterte 15 kilometer von calais
entfernt seit der räumung des
flüchtlingslagers dort vor fünf jahren
kommen immer wieder migranten nach
calais um über den ärmelkanal nach
großbritannien zu gelangen
fast täglich versuchen das gruppen mit
zum teil sehr tüchtigen boten paris und
london werfen sich gegenseitig vor nicht
genug gegen die illegale migration zu
tun
mit wirtschafts geht's weiter gundula
macht weiter mit dem blick auf die
wirtschaft an diesem tag
zentrales thema der wirtschafts und
finanzwelt war heute auch der
koalitionsvertrag der neuen
bundesregierung vor allem die frage nach
der finanzierung viele vorhaben sehen
verbände und ökonomen als nicht
ausreichend beantwortet valerie haller
wie bewerten finanzexperten den
koalitionsvertrag ganz unterschiedliche
natürlich aber viel lob gab es dafür
dass der koalitionsvertrag so schnell
zustande gekommen ist positiv sehen
viele auch das klare bekenntnis zur
digitalisierung innovation und
investitionen ja und fragen gab es
tatsächlich vielfach zur finanzierung
zumal die regierung mit klimawandel
stabilisierung des rentensystems und
einer besseren infrastruktur
herkules aufgaben zu bewältigen hat
gleichzeitig sollen die steuern aber
nicht steigen wer soll das also bezahlen
das fragt auch das institut für
wettbewerbsökonomie
denn weder steuererhöhungen noch eine
echte reform der schuldenbremse stehen
zur debatte beim thema steuern sähen
viele ohnehin nicht den ganz großen wurf
weder werden die unternehmen entlastet
noch hoch verdiener mehr besteuert die
geplanten änderungen halten sich in
engen grenzen folglich gibt es keine
eindeutigen gewinner und verlierer meint
die dekabank
viel gegenwind bekommt die ampel
koalition für ihren plan den mindestlohn
auf 12 euro anzuheben die politische
festlegung des mindestlohns kommt einer
entmachtung der mindestlohn kommission
gleich wettert der handelsverband
interessant für börsianer die geplante
aktien rente künftig sollen teile der
rentenbeiträge in einen aktienfonds
fließen die hoffnung ist mehr rendite
doch auch hier wird die finanzierung
noch fragen auf
vielen dank valerie nach frankfurt
fußball nationalspieler joshua kimmig
ist positiv auf das corona virus
getestet worden ebenso wie sein
vereinskollege choupo moting das
bestätigte der fc bayern münchen und
erklärte kim ich gehe es gut der 26
jährige mittelfeldspieler hatte vor
kurzem heftige diskussionen ausgelöst
mit seiner erklärung wegen fehlender
langzeitstudien nicht geimpft zu sein
gleich noch eine meldung aus dem all
zunächst die gewinnzahlen vom lotto sie
lauten 2 59 19 24 25 superzahl 7 weitere
gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf de und im zdf
text auf seite 55 7 wie kann man die
erde vor dem einschlag eines asteroiden
schützen zwar sehen wissenschaftler
absehbar keine konkrete gefahr aber sie
haben rund
27.000 kleinplaneten in der nähe der
erde identifiziert so hat die nasa von
kalifornien aus eine sonde erstmals
absichtlich auf kollisionskurs ins all
geschickt sie soll im oktober 22 mit dem
asteroiden die more fonds
zusammenprallen und so dessen flugbahn
verändern es ist die erste mission von
dart einem forschungsprogramm der nasa
zur abwehr von gefahren aus dem weltraum
um die abwehr irdischer gefahren geht es
gleich im anschluss im auslandsjournal
spezial unter dem titel corona global
unter anderem mit einer reportage aus
österreich im lock down
und gegen 0.50 meldet sich hier
christopher wehrmann mit unserem
heute-journal update auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
kunde und herzlich willkommen zum wetter
bevor wir auf schnee und kälte schauen
blicken wir mal zurück auf das ja und
zwar auf die sommertage definiert 25
grad und mehr
es gab für deutschlandweit 37 tage das
sind gut zehn tage mehr als im schnitt
aber die waren auch sehr unterschiedlich
verteilt deutlich mehr gab es zum
beispiel entlang des rheins bis zum
oberrhein oder im osten teilweise mehr
als 50 60 maximal waren es 72 tage die
mehr als 25 grad hatten schauen wir mal
auf die kelter die kommt aus dem norden
mit diesem tief von island runter und
morgen erst einmal nur zu den britischen
inseln erreicht uns dann am freitag
ansonsten haben wir es von süden her mit
einem tief zu tun und das bringt dann
auch zum freitag den schnee vor allem
richtung bayern erste mal in der
kommenden nacht im norden etwas
sprühregen sonst klart es nach süden hin
auf teilweise bildet sich dichter nebel
dort wo es keine wolken gibt wird es
kalt bis minus fünf grad 7 grad in
schleswig holstein dort also frostfrei
morgen im tagesverlauf kommt etwas regen
auf vor allem im norden und der zieht
allmählich weiter südwärts auch richtung
emsland und im westen paar tropfen sonst
aber auch mal sonnige abschnitte zb nach
osten in bei höchsten temperaturen von
minus 1 grad unter dem dichten nebel und
9 grad in schleswig holstein ja und der
schnee am freitag dann in den
mittelgebirgen im westen ansonsten im
süden auch teils dichter schneefall null
bis fünf grad und auch die folgenden
tage ist immer wieder schnee dabei ein
schöner abend